here is the actor who plays the title
role in Schindler's List Liam Neeson
this is the nights people from the back
lot and the back room step to the front
we who labor in front of the camera
applaud them everyday we work from the
craft service folks who serve the crew
coffee to the negative cutters in the
processing lives from the sharp-eyed
script supervisors who catch our
mistakes and the lovely people in
payroll view issue our checks they are
all unheralded contributors to our
movies I am privileged to Herald one
group of contributors the three nominees
for sound effects editing are
wilee stateman and greg Baxter for
cliffhanger John Levesque and Bruce
Stambler for the fugitive Gary Rydstrom
and Richard hymns for Jurassic Park it's
my honor to announce the winner is the
Oscar goes to Gary Wright strum and
Richard hims Jurassic Park
well that's not it that's the rest of
Frank Sinatra's speech with that in mind
with that in mind I'd like to go right
up front and thank my parents Fred and
Barbara and the rest of our family back
in England my family Cindy of my family
for knowing that I'm not usually just
wouldn't and we'd also like to thank we
also like to thank Steven Spielberg
Universal Pictures and everyone at
Amblin especially Michael Kahn and Colin
Wilson also thanks to Kate Coombs and
Kiki Morris and everyone at Skywalker
North also sound effects editors Terry
Acton Ken Fisher and Tim Holland and my
amazing assistant Ruth hasty my amazing
assistant Chris boys and Foley artist
Danny Thorpe Sen Tina Bailey Lake Mary
Helen Leachman and the rest of our
editing team who really do the work and
sharing this award
thank you very much